[THEME MUSIC]
EDMOND CHAN: Hello, and welcome.
I'm Edmond from Square,
and with me are Lak
and Yufeng from Google.
We're going to be
talking to you today
about useful patterns for
developing, operationalizing,
and maintaining machine
learning models.
Machine learning
involves a few steps.
From organizing your
data, you gather it,
engineer your features,
create and train the model,
and you finally deploy it.
But it's actually iterative.
You need to-- there we go.
I didn't know there's
an animation there.
It's actually quite iterative.
You need to first organize
your data-- sorry.
You're not done once
you've trained and deployed
your model.
You need to continuously
monitor its performance,
add features,
retrain periodically.
It's a team effort involving
data analysts, data engineers,
and data scientists.
Typically, your
subject matter experts,
your data engineers
will gather all the data
with inputs from
data scientists.
Your data scientists
will join all the data,
create the features,
create and train the model.
And data engineers will be
responsible for maintaining
the training prediction
infrastructure.
And everyone will monitor
model performance, all
the different aspects of it.
Data analysts will be
focused on the outputs
of the model, their
distributions, how actionable
they are, whether they're
enabling good decisions or not.
Data scientists will be more
focused on the distributions
of the inputs themselves.
Any shifts in those
might represent
a problem with your
data ingestion pipeline,
or maybe a shift
in the population.
And the data engineers
will be focusing
on uptime and resilience.
And thus, because we have so
many people working on so many
moving parts simultaneously,
operationalizing
ML models is actually
quite difficult.
And now Lak is going to discuss
some of those challenges.
VALLIAPPA LAKSHMANAN:
Thanks, Edmond.
Yeah, so operationalizing
an ML model,
by which we mean going from a
trained model to a model that's
deployed in production that
you can use to make predictions
with, that's hard.
And that's the
chasm in our title.
There's this big chasm
between training the model
and getting it into production.
So let's talk
about, number one--
or number zero-- why is it so
hard to put a machine learning
model into production?
What makes it hard?
I mean, it's just software.
We know how to deploy software.
So I mean, what is so
special about machine
learning models that
it's so hard to put them
into production?
So first thing is this whole
concept of reproducibility.
The thing is, when
you train your model,
what are you training on?
You're essentially training
on historical data, data that
now is in a data warehouse.
You basically are taking that
data, it's in a data warehouse,
and then you're training
your model on it.
But when you come
to predictions,
what are you predicting on?
You're not making
your predictions
on data in the data warehouse.
That's historical data.
What you care about is
predictions in a real time
stream.
You're making predictions
on data that's coming in.
So it may be software,
but these two
are different software systems.
You have one software
system that's
about historical data and
data preservation and so on.
And you have another
software system
that's about real time,
that's about getting things
very quickly, that's
about user interactivity.
It's about speed.
So they're very, very
different kinds of systems.
And everything that you
do in the training step
has to be repeated in
the deployment step.
And that reproducibility
is very hard.
So if we look at
patterns that help
us get that reproducibility
so that the steps that you did
during training,
you can basically
repeat them or reproduce them
in your deployment system.
The second thing is that
everything that you do
needs to be portable
between the training system
and the deployment system.
And unfortunately,
these two things--
the hardware and the software--
are often very different.
You might train on the cloud,
but you might do an inference
on a phone.
It may be the same software.
But the software that runs on
the cloud, obviously the system
is very different
than something that's
going to run on the phone.
And you need everything that
you do, all your ML models,
all your ML systems, to be
portable between the hardware
and the software that's actually
different between the training
and inference systems.
So we look at portability
patterns, ways
to make sure that
things remain portable.
The third thing is that
whatever platform that you use,
it needs to be flexible.
And the reason it
needs to be flexible
is that your skill sets
on the training side
and the priorities
are very different from the
skill sets and priorities
on the inference side.
On the training side,
who's doing the training?
It's going to be
your data people.
And what do they care about?
Data, number one.
But they also care about
things like accuracy.
Can I train on all the data?
They care about scale.
But when they talk
about scale, they're
talking about scale
in terms of, am I
able to scale to all my data?
They're talking about research.
They're talking about being
able to use better models,
to be able to use the
most advanced models that
are available.
And they're also talking
about the models themselves,
being able to basically
accommodate them.
So that's on the training side.
So their priorities are
in terms of accuracy,
in terms of scale, in terms
of being able to train
on all their data.
And their skill sets tend
to be things like statistics
and Python and so on.
Now, look on the other side.
On the inference side,
who's doing the inference?
It's your engineering team.
What do they care about?
Resilience.
They don't want
the thing to crash.
They don't want the
pager to go off.
That's the number one priority.
The priority is very different.
They also care about scale.
But the scale that an
engineer cares about
is different from the scale
that your data scientist
cares about.
Your data scientist wants
to train on all the data.
The engineer wants to
make sure that they
can handle all million users
that are going to hit your web
page at lunchtime.
The scale that they're talking
about is very different.
They care about the
engineering quality.
They care about maintainability.
They care about speed.
They care about applications.
So the priorities and
skill sets are different.
And so if you pick a
machine learning platform,
any platform you pick has to
be flexible to accommodate
both of these types of users.
And finally, you need to
basically deal with agility.
And as kind of a joke, but
you kind of train your model
on historical data.
You train your model on things
that look like dinosaurs.
And then you start
running your model,
and they basically
are dealt with birds.
Your data has drifted,
has evolved over time,
and you basically get something
that is kind of the same thing,
but not quite the same thing.
And you need that agility to
deal with this model drift
because, guess what?
The real world, things
change over time.
So the thing that you
trained on and the thing
that you're predicting on, there
is going to be model drift.
And the question is,
how do you recognize it?
How do you accommodate for it?
How do you fix it?
So we look at patterns
that deal with agility.
So first to talk about
reproducibility patterns.
So first one, so what
are some of the ways
that we basically
get reproducibility?
So first thing is
what we talked about.
You train on historical data.
You predict on real-time
streaming data.
So how do you deal with that?
You want to basically reuse your
pipeline, your data pipeline,
your data preprocessing, as much
as possible between your batch
historical system and your
streaming real-time system.
To date, there is
still only one system,
one API that allows
you to do data
processing with the same code
on both batch and stream.
And that's Beam, Apache Beam.
In fact, the B-E--
B is for batch, and
E-A-M is for stream.
So it's about a single,
consistent thing
that lets you deal
with batch and stream
so that you can basically
have the same code.
And in our case,
we run Apache Beam
on Google Cloud and Dataflow.
That's why you see Dataflow
in the diagram there.
But the code that you
write is open source.
It's Apache Beam.
So pattern number
one, Apache Beam
to reuse this pipeline code
between training and inference.
So the reason that we do
this is because all the data
transformations that you need
to do on the training dataset,
they have to get applied
during inference, too.
So you take your raw data.
You preprocess it.
You clean it.
You create features.
And it is these
features that you
give to your training model.
And now your
training model needs
to basically do predictions.
And so you take that trained
model and you deploy it.
But to that deployed web
application, what comes about
is essentially the raw
inputs that the clients need.
It's exactly the same
data that they need.
The question now is, how are we
going to do this pre-processing
and feature creation
so that reproducibility
is super important?
How do we reproduce everything
that we did in our training
system on the inference side?
So there are a couple
of ways to do it.
If, for example, you do
preprocessing in TensorFlow,
you can do this reproduction.
So you have your
preprocessing code.
You have your feature
creation code.
And then you create
your preprocess features
and you train your
model on them.
It is very efficient.
And if you are using
the Estimator API,
you basically have something
that is called feature columns.
And everything that you
do in a feature column
will be remembered in
the TensorFlow graph.
So when you checkpoint
a TensorFlow model,
all of those preprocessing
steps are saved in the graph
so that when you then go out to
go predict it, it's automatic.
All of those steps
that you did get
carried out because you
used feature columns.
So that is great.
But there are a couple
of caveats here.
The first caveat is that
it's only things that you
do in a feature column.
It's only things that you
use TensorFlow methods with.
What if you did
preprocessing that doesn't
happen in the feature column?
Now you have to deal
with it some other way.
The second thing is, and
this is a very general,
high-level restriction,
your TensorFlow model, when
you train it, what does it see?
It essentially sees
a batch of examples.
But in that sense, it only
sees one example at a time.
It doesn't actually
see examples in order.
So any of the preprocessing
that you do on that one training
example is fine.
But if your preprocessing
involves a moving average,
will you ever have a
moving average as an input?
Sure, right?
If you ever have a
moving average, that
moving average, the way you
compute the moving average,
there's nothing you can do
inside the TensorFlow feature
transform to do that.
It doesn't work because
the TensorFlow model only
sees that one example.
It doesn't know how you
computed that feature
in the first place.
So there is that second issue.
So it's efficient,
but it's restricted
to TensorFlow methods
in a feature column,
and it's only that one input.
The other approach
that you can do
is that you can do this
thing in Apache Beam.
So that's what I
just showed you.
You do it in that Beam pipeline.
You do your actual
preprocessing,
you compute your moving
average in Apache Beam.
So that's great.
It has state.
You compute it in Python,
you compute it in Java.
And you compute that
feature and you're training
the model on the feature.
Then when you're
doing the predictions,
you run the exact same pipeline
to create the exact same moving
average and you give
it to your model.
So this way now it
sees a full dataset.
It scales really well
because Beam is distributed.
But it cannot take
advantage of accelerators.
What do you mean
by accelerators?
GPUs, TPUs, et cetera.
This is OK if it's
a moving average.
It's not OK if you're
basically running
the first half of
the inception model,
so basically create an embedding
that you're basically using
as an input to your model.
Now creating that
feature is so expensive.
You can't really do that
in something like Beam.
So how do we basically
do reproducibility
that can accommodate for
both of these things?
And that's what
tf.transform does.
So TensorFlow
transform is a library
that is a hybrid of Apache
Beam and TensorFlow.
How is it a hybrid?
You do your analysis during
training in Apache Beam.
So you can look at
all your dataset.
You can compute your
moving averages.
You can find your
mins and maxes.
You can find your unique values.
You can do all of
those things in Beam.
And then at prediction
time in TensorFlow
you can actually apply
those transformations.
So you get the scale
of Beam and you get
the efficiency of TensorFlow.
And everything is
remembered from what
you did during
training to what you
need to do during prediction.
So pattern number one
for reproducibility,
TensorFlow transform.
So you basically get, as I said,
the efficiency of TensorFlow
during inference and the
scalability of the Beam
during training.
So it's not just Beam.
It's not just TensorFlow.
It's that right
combination of the two.
The second thing that
you want to think
about when it comes
to reproducibility
gets back into the development
of the model itself.
And this is where you want to
make sure that you are never
copying data because every
time you make a copy of data,
you run this risk that the
thing that you train on
and the thing that you're
going to predict on,
there have been
other things that
have happened in the middle.
So one of the things
that we always suggest
is keep your data in BigQuery.
You can share the data set.
You can share your
queries in BigQuery.
You can actually save your
data on cloud storage.
And you can run a
federated query.
So you can run your SQL query
on the data that exists already
in Cloud Storage or in Cloud
Bigtable or on Google Drive.
But the point being, don't
make copies of your data.
Don't move your data around.
Keep your data in place.
Join it in place.
Share the data sets.
Share the queries so
that different people can
run different analytics on it.
So join your data in place.
Don't move it around.
So if you have structured data,
if you have streaming data,
use BigQuery.
If you have archival
data, unstructured data,
use Cloud Storage.
If you have transactional
data, time series data,
internet of things data,
use Cloud Bigtable.
If you have business types of
data, spreadsheets, et cetera,
use Google Drive.
And the cool thing is
that all of these things,
you can run a
federated query on.
So you can keep
your data in place
and don't make copies of it.
And by not making
copies of it, you
can limit your
reproducibility problems.
And then you can
access that same data
with different kinds of tools.
So as we just talked about,
you can do federated queries
with BigQuery.
But you can use
Dataflow and Apache
Beam so you can do your
batch and stream processing.
So you explore your
data in BigQuery.
And then you train and
you predict with Dataflow.
You haven't changed the data.
You haven't moved the data.
So you don't have to worry that
this data that you explored
and this data that
you're training, again,
are actually different.
So you can do Dataproc,
Hadoop and Spark workloads
in machine learning, et cetera.
And this allows you to
democratize your data
in sites across your org.
You can save and
share your queries.
You can create good
reports with BigQuery.
You can share them as Sheets.
You can use partner tools like
Tableau, Looker, et cetera,
to share this data.
But the key principle here
is, keep the data in place.
Do your analytics
with multiple tools,
but don't move your data around.
And to talk about how
Square does this, Edmond.
EDMOND CHAN: So the rules
governing how much Square
should pay its
financial partners
for processing any given
payment are extremely Byzantine.
They're scattered across
multiple rulebooks,
with each card, network, and
currency having its own book.
Some of these books are
over 1,000 page long.
And they change twice a year,
every April and October.
So it's actually
quite difficult for us
to know how much we should be
paying for any one payment.
It's far too difficult
to generate and maintain
a rules engine.
So what we've done is we've
created a machine learning
model to verify our cost for
us, the transaction cost anomaly
detector, or TCAD.
Oh, sorry.
Through TCAD, we've
discovered over $2 million
worth of transaction anomalies.
Much of it was recoverable
because they were bona fide
transaction cost errors.
And a large part of achieving
that result has been limiting
training-serving
skew, which we've
done by using the same queries,
using the same BigQuery tables,
have training and inference,
therefore both times we're
using the same data.
We've also performed all
of our pre-processing
within TensorFlow using the
TF feature column module.
And this ensures that at
training and inference,
we're using the
same vocabularies
for categorical features,
the same scaling
for our numeric features.
This has worked
quite well for us.
But it does require us to first
define these vocabularies,
define these numeric ranges
and encode them in our model.
In future iterations,
we're most likely
going to be moving towards
TensorFlow transform
to further simplify
this process.
Now, another pattern that
we've been using in TCAD
is portability.
And to see that, let's take a
look at the TCAD architecture
itself.
Now, let's start at the
top left with the training.
We have our historical cost
data stored in BigQuery.
And we're training with
that data on ML Engine.
And then when it comes
time for inference,
which is the lower
half of this diagram,
we have our trained model
stored in Cloud Storage.
And we have a data pipeline,
a Cloud Dataflow pipeline,
which also takes our historical
cost data from BigQuery,
the same sources training,
and computes or estimates
what our true costs
should be, compares
that against our actual cost,
computes aggregates, passes
them all along to Stackdriver,
where we have dashboards
and alerts, and, if necessary,
additional human review
and further action.
This has all been
working great for us.
But we didn't start with that.
We have to go from an on-premise
solution to a complete cloud
solution where we moved
all our data to BigQuery.
We moved our storage to
Google Cloud Storage.
And we moved our inference
and data processing pipeline
to Dataflow.
But all along the way,
we were able to retain
the same TensorFlow model.
VALLIAPPA LAKSHMANAN:
Thanks, Edmond.
So as Edmond said, the key
idea is this whole idea
of portability, that they were
able to make all these changes,
but at the bottom
of it, they were
able to keep the exact
same TensorFlow model.
And that's one thing that I
think you keep hearing over
and over again, is
this idea of being
able to do porting from on-prem
to cloud, from your cloud
to your device, et cetera.
And TensorFlow is a big part
of providing that portability.
So why do you need portability?
When we designed
TensorFlow, this whole idea
was that we needed to
support different training
and inference environments.
So when you talk about
where do you train,
you might train on the cloud.
You might train on
a Kubernetes system.
You might train with
programs written in Python.
TensorFlow is all
Python, primarily.
The training code might
need accelerators,
like GPUs or your
custom ASIC chips,
like Tensor processing units.
So you need that
portability that happens.
The fact that training
happens on all these kinds
of environments, then you go
over to the inference side.
Where do people do inference?
Where do they run predictions?
Well, they may run
predictions in Kubernetes.
They may run it on GKE
with Kubernetes Engine.
They may run it as part
of a web application.
They may run it
in mobile devices.
They might run it on JavaScript.
How many of you have
you heard of TensorFlow
on JavaScript, TensorFlow.js?
That's part of the
portability idea.
You train the
model on the cloud,
but you run it inside
your web browser.
You run it with Java.
The fact that you trained it,
created your model with Python,
doesn't mean that you have
to run it in a Python system.
That's a very key, important
design goal behind TensorFlow
is to support all these
different training
and inference environments.
So the pattern here
is use TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is what gives
you that portability.
And in terms of
these environments,
I like to think of it
as three different types
of environments.
You have the environments
that are all about simplicity.
You have a fully
managed Cloud ML engine.
Everything is there.
You don't have to
spin up a cluster.
You just submit
your TensorFlow code
and you have your model trained.
Or if you want to do
development of a model
and you just want a VM
with TensorFlow and Jupyter
and everything that you would
typically need in data science,
you want all of that
directly installed,
there is a deep learning image.
You can go to the
Cloud Launcher page,
launch a deep-learning
image, and it basically
has different versions of
TensorFlow, different GPUs
that you can attach to it, and
you can basically get going.
So that's the
simplicity end of it.
On the fast side
of things, you want
to do things very,
very, very fast.
You want to train very fast.
You know the cloud GPUs,
you have GPUs on the cloud.
But in between, you
might need portability.
You might need things.
You might need to run
inference not on the cloud.
And that's where
Kubeflow comes in.
Kubeflow is TensorFlow in
Kubernetes, an open source
project led by Google.
And then you have TensorFlow,
which runs in Python and C++
and JavaScript and
Java, TensorFlow Lite,
which runs on mobile devices.
So you have all of
these different choices.
And third, to talk about
flexibility, Yufeng.
YUFENG GUO: OK, so we've talked
about our first two points.
Flexibility comes in kind of
almost when you reverse around.
Instead of saying,
for the same model,
if I switch the world around
the model, what happens?
There's also the consideration
of when it comes time
to change the model,
how can we do that
without then altering the
world around that model
significantly?
So when it comes
to model building,
there's a very wide
library of choices now.
There's lots of
different libraries
you can use to build your model.
You can use scikit-learn.
You can use XGBoost, Keras,
TensorFlow, and many others.
There's also the TensorFlow Hub.
If you haven't seen
that, I would really
encourage checking that out.
TF Hub.
It's a really neat place
to see the different models
that folks are building.
The hope is that
you will not only
be able to get value out
TF Hub to get models that
are out in the community,
research models,
things like that, but also
then be able to contribute back
to the community things
that you have found,
the new models that
you've developed.
And so whether you're
building just your standard,
fully-connected networks
or convolution networks
or more sophisticated things
like recurrent nets and things
like that, having
flexibility in what model
you use-- because sometimes
you might start with one,
do your initial analysis, and
then for the same type of data,
change fundamentally the
kind of model you're using.
So that means you want to think
about what kind of interface
your model is providing to
your downstream consumers,
such that you're able
to swap things out,
just general good software
engineering practices when
it comes to layers of
abstraction and things
like that.
And the other thing
I wanted to note
is that Keras is now
also part of TensorFlow.
So you can call tf.keras.
I think it was 1.8 and
above that supports that.
And that there's
interesting ways
now you can combine model
building using Keras.
So Keras has a really great,
simple model-building API
that is really easy to use.
And you can combine that
with TensorFlow's execution
speed and estimator frameworks.
You can stick the Keras
model inside an estimator
and then run that, which gives
you access to distributed
training, accelerators, all
without having to rework
the wiring of your model.
And so that brings us to
kind of the next point.
Where do you hook up the model
to, and the considerations
around having flexibility in
the consumption of your data.
There's really highly
structured data.
It may come from a variety
of different sources.
And as you experiment with
the type and amount of data
you feed your model
during this training
process, this
iterative process, you
might find that you either
need to add more data,
change from one dataset to
another, or add something in,
and that it may go from
fitting into memory
and being really easy to do
on a laptop to being something
significantly larger.
Or maybe you go from
having unstructured
data that's in a data lake and
you move to structured data.
And then you have to think
about how you're going to port
that data over and
connect that in.
So having flexibility in
how your model consumes
the different types of
data that it may encounter
through its lifetime is an
important design decision
as you go about
kind of this task--
swapping out models,
swapping out datas.
And thirdly, the notion of
being able to iterate quickly.
So this is kind of a specific
note for more complex models.
And when I say complex
models, I don't just
mean models that are, in and
of themselves, "sophisticated",
quote unquote, but
also situations
where you have a
requirement where
you need to train a
large amount of data
and run that through the model
during training before you can
get a meaningful outcome, or to
even know if your training is
going in the right direction.
And so for that, you want to
be able to train and iterate
with a reasonable
amount of speed.
And there's a couple of ways
that you can achieve speed.
If you say, well, training
iterations are fast for me
because each time I do
a new training cycle,
it only takes 30 seconds.
Great.
You're all set.
And so you can just try
something, try something,
try something in series.
But what if each time you do
a training cycle, after you've
already maxed out
all your options when
it comes to compute
resources, it still
takes 30 minutes or 30 hours
to do one training iteration?
That's when it comes time
to think about other ways.
You have to think outside of
just doing one attempt and then
a different attempt
and moving on.
And so being able to kick
off multiple training
jobs in parallel
that are isolated
from each other, such
that you can experiment
across a spectrum of different
models, different parameters,
and potentially even different
features, different input
datas that go into your model.
And so one kind of
plug I'll make here
is that Cloud ML Engine
supports these various facets
of quick iteration when it comes
to larger data sets and bigger
training jobs.
You can train multiple jobs.
You kick off a job.
You configure it
with your model.
You feed it your data.
And it's off to the races.
And then you can
set up another one.
You kick off another job.
And you can choose to use
the same data set or maybe
a different data set, same model
or different model, et cetera.
And you can kick off
multiple training tasks.
But then with each
training task itself, you
can also configure
different hyperparameters.
So there is built into ML Engine
a hyperparameter tuning service
called HyperTune, fittingly.
And it will basically try
out different variants
of the same model
and try to help you,
guide you in which
set of hyperparameters
would be most appropriate.
And it will basically
do these in parallel.
So you're kicking
off parallel jobs.
Each parallel job is kicking
off parallel jobs in itself.
So you're getting this
incredible scaling effect
and making yourself super,
super productive, which
means you can just
go make a sandwich
or something at that point.
OK, so the other
piece of flexibility I
want to point out-- when we
talk about model building,
now we flip over to deployment.
When we're making
predictions, making inference,
there's a couple of
different options and things
you want to keep in mind.
One is model stacking.
Once your model is deployed,
it may be in a situation
where you actually have the
outputs of one model feeding
in as inputs to a second model.
And maybe that model's outputs
feed into a third model.
And at first you
might look at this
and say, ah, that's
too sophisticated.
I'm not going to have three
models feeding each other.
That's silly.
But a lot of times the things
that we do in the preprocessing
step can actually be
thought of in this context.
What is the first thing
that happens to your data
when you make some of
these transformations?
Depending on what they
are, if they're not
something super trivial,
like the time series
averaging, if you're
doing something
a little more
sophisticated, than you
could think of it as
you are kind of modeling
your data in some way.
And that might change.
And you're going to need that to
show up in deployment, as well.
And so when you have that
situation, the interface
between your
different models, they
need to not
encounter bottlenecks
because at deployment
time, any bottleneck starts
really accruing and your latency
starts building up like crazy.
And then the second point
is swapping out models.
Your data science team goes
and they develop a model.
Here I'm calling it model four
because it's the next number.
And then a couple of weeks
later, they're like, hey,
we found some new data.
It looks kind of
different and we
decided to try a
totally different model.
The interface is
kind of similar,
but it's a different model.
It's really different.
And so we need to
swap that out live.
Can we do that?
So what happens when we want
to swap in model five like that
and still have
everything keep working?
And so if you're in
a situation where
you should be able
to do that, that's
something you have
to engineer upfront
because if you don't
and you need to do that,
you're going to be in a hole.
And thirdly, scaling
the inference.
Support predictions.
When you have lots
and lots of requests,
standing up a production
server is no easy feat.
But standing up
multiple really quickly
because lots of
requests are coming in
is arguably even harder.
And so the other
side of ML Engine--
aside from the training and the
GPUs and the TPUs and all that
awesome stuff--
is that you can take and
export a TensorFlow model,
and just give it a name and
point to it and say, here.
ML Engine, take that
model and deploy it for me
and autoscale that for me.
And yes, I would also
like a REST API for that.
And obviously, it
should be secured.
And you can just take all
those things for granted.
You literally just
give it a name,
put down the path to the
file, and click Save.
So with that, I'll
pass it over to Edmond
to talk a little bit about
how they implement flexibility
at Square.
EDMOND CHAN: So 2.75%, it's
what Square is famous for.
It's what we charge for
processing in-person card
payments.
But as you can see from the
smaller text below that,
we actually offer custom
rate packages, as well.
And generating those
custom rate packages
relies on model stacking
and model choice.
Let's start and walk through
this diagram backwards,
actually.
Let's begin from the
top right with 2.48%.
That's our custom rate package.
And what made it?
A Keras model did,
a Keras model that
accepted inputs, that
information that our sales
team has gathered
through their dialogue
with the prospective seller.
That Keras model itself was
trained on Cloud Machine
Learning engine.
And here's where the
model stacking happens.
One of the inputs
to this Keras model
is actually a
separate model, a word
embedding that
we've actually used
through a few other
models, as well.
One of the other
patterns that we're
going to talk through today
is agility with Yufeng.
YUFENG GUO: So next thing, the
final of our four, is agility.
Lak introduced it with the
example of dinosaurs and birds,
or eagle, in that case.
And the implication here
being that the world changes.
That's why you're all here
because machine learning has
put down some sweeping changes
on the landscape of computing,
the landscape of technology.
So a couple of models
and mental models
for thinking about how we can
be agile when it comes to data
and when it comes
to machine learning.
The first is failing fast.
When you have new
ideas, finding ways
to test out those new
ideas quickly and cheaply.
So if you have a new idea for
an architecture for a house,
maybe you build it
out of ginger house.
Maybe you don't.
You use a CAD
software or something.
But I chose to build
a gingerbread house
and that's what happened
there, so apologies for that.
And when you want to fail
fast, what you can do
is take a subset of your data.
This new data client comes in.
You're like, oh,
let me try this out.
Let me see if I can get
anything useful out of it.
But it's not enough to just
randomly sample some new data.
In a lot of cases, you want
to be selective in pulling out
a particular subset of
that data, the part that
is particularly
interesting to you.
Just because you know that
this new data in aggregate
is something that
is new, something
that is different from
what you've seen before,
doesn't necessarily mean
that a random sample
will bring about some kind
of new insight for you.
But if you already
know something
about the nature of
this new data, use it.
Use it to your advantage and
kind of query your data out
and export a chunk of it that
is representative of what
it is you're trying to evoke.
The second aspect of agility is
to basically keep developing.
Just because a model
is in production
does not mean you're done.
In fact, you've just started.
You've just gotten
across the starting line.
I have a model in production.
Now it's doing stuff.
But now we want to continue to
improve that model, especially
with this new live data.
The example of the dinosaur
data and the bird data
is interesting because
once you start build,
your model's in production and
the new live data is coming in.
As soon as that
happens, the new data
is now your historical data.
If you can take that new data
and then utilize it to upgrade
or update your models
going forward--
let's say you deploy your
model and two months later,
you're able to take that two
months worth of data and do
something useful with it--
then you can improve
your existing model.
You don't need to just
use historical data
from the past past.
You can have the recent past.
And finally, kind of frequent
retraining, this notion
of once in a while,
you might need
to just blow it
up and start over.
And that's OK because
whether it's a new model--
you might train
it on a new model.
Or you might say,
this model has been
trained on data from
the past five years.
But we started by training
the data from the older
three of those five years.
And in the past two
years that the model
has been in production,
we've updated
and updated and updated.
But there is a lot of cruft.
It's almost like when you're
developing a software system.
You build that initial
release, and then
over the next two
years, you add patches.
You put some duct tape here.
You add some string over there.
And at the end of two
years, it doesn't even
look like the thing you
originally designed.
And so maybe you start over.
You build over here.
And you say, let's
start and say,
if I wanted to build
this from scratch today,
how would that look like?
Would I still use
the same models?
Would I still even
use the same features?
As machine learning, a field
that's moving so quickly, now,
as that kind of
progresses, it will likely
change the answers
to those questions,
and relatively quickly.
And so concretely, what
that often amounts to
is taking your deployed
model and having something
like model versioning.
We all have software versioning.
We have Git and
things like that.
So we should also do
the same with models.
And one are the key
benefits of this
is being able to roll back.
When you deploy a new
version of a model,
you want to be
able to say, oops.
Actually, no, I
don't want that one.
Let me go back to the
old one real quick.
Or maybe you deploy
it and it works.
And then the weekend comes.
And then you realize
your model doesn't
generalize to the weekend.
So then you roll back.
Maybe you have three new
models and different teams
made them and they are
competing for saying,
hey, it should be mine.
Then the other team also says,
no, no, it should be our model.
Our model is better.
So split testing, being
able to divert your traffic
in an appropriate manner
across different models
to say which model is actually
the better or more useful
model.
And the second point here is,
in terms of staying agile,
is thinking of your system
in this kind of chain.
From training all the
way to deployment,
all these different
levels of abstraction
that you have
access to, you might
start by working with something
like a pre-trained model
or something from
TF Hub, something
that is already well-documented,
well-maintained,
and established as
a model that works.
And as you go along,
as time passes,
you might become more
sophisticated in your approach
and customize that model.
And maybe you then retrain
it and do all these things.
But having good
layers of abstraction
allow you to make these
changes without kind
of colliding with yourself.
And so to talk a little
more about agility
and how they've
approached it at Square,
turn it back over to Edmond.
EDMOND CHAN: So what's
this screen here?
It's the declined screen.
It's what our sellers
and their customers
see whenever one of
our financial partners
declines a transaction.
We don't like
seeing this screen.
It represents a lost
sale for our sellers,
and for us it's lost
revenue from missing out
on facilitating that sale.
In order to minimize
declines, we're
actually working
on automatically
retrying declines.
But each decline has a cost.
So clearly, we don't
want to retry everything,
because some of those
retries will inevitably
decline themselves.
But we do have a model to help
us decide which ones to retry.
And this diagram is a lot
simpler than the other ones
I've shown to you.
And there's really only
two key points here.
The first is that inference is
done in our payment systems,
which are written in Java.
The training was done in
Python using a TensorFlow
pre-made classifier.
And what that has
allowed us to do
is to go from nothing
to handing off
a trained model to
the engineering teams
to integrate into our
payment processing systems.
And while they're working
on integrating that system,
I'm free to continue to collect
more data to refine our model
and to refine our
decision criteria.
And finally, when it comes
time to swap models in and out
for testing, it's
just one line of code
that needs to be
changed, not much.
YUFENG GUO: Take the mic.
VALLIAPPA LAKSHMANAN: Sure.
All right.
So to summarize, then, patterns
to develop, operationalize,
and maintain ML
models, number one,
need to exactly reproduce
the training steps
in your deployment system.
And as Edmond
pointed out, the idea
is to limit the
training-serving skew
in the machine learning model.
So use identical
BigQuery queries.
Use TensorFlow feature columns.
Use TensorFlow transform.
The second pattern
is to be portable
between different
hardware and software used
for training and inference.
And the point of that
is to basically use
a system, a machine
learning framework, that
offers you that portability.
Don't go for the next
new, shiny thing.
There is value in basically
going with something that's
mature, that's supported on a
variety of different platforms.
The third aspect of
this is basically
allowing for flexibility in
model development and model
deployment.
So the idea there is basically
to be able to change models,
to be able to basically
stack models together,
do all of these things,
to have different
versions of a model.
All these are very,
very, very important
in a production system.
And when you design a
machine learning system,
you should plan for your
model to go obsolete,
for things to be changed.
And make sure that
your client code
doesn't rely on a
very specific model,
but is basically acting on it
through a layer of indirection.
And finally, this
idea of staying
agile, to be able to iterate
and to deploy updates.
As Edmond pointed
out, their idea
was to basically give
their engineering
team an initial version of
a model and then go ahead
and keep collecting data to
create the next better model.
That's a great way
to approach it.
So don't think that you have
to build it all at once.
But understand that
as new data come in,
you're going to basically
get a newer and better model.
But you have to have something
out there immediately.
So don't let the perfect
be the enemy of the good.
So to summarize, then,
these are the patterns
that we talked about for
reproducibility, portability,
flexibility, and agility.
Number one, joining
your data in place,
sharing queries,
sharing data sets,
preprocessing your data using
Apache Beam and tf.transform,
running TensorFlow in
hybrid environments,
thinking about training on the
cloud, predicting on the edge,
gaining flexibility with
Cloud, with Kubeflow,
building the right abstraction
level in machine learning,
and building in the
ability in your systems
to be able to roll
model versions
and to continuously retrain
machine learning models.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[THEME MUSIC]